Why is the Moon so big?
Actually, it’s all in your head.
What?!?!?!
Hey Crazies.
Have you ever looked at the Moon when it’s
really low in the sky?
It has that reddish-orange color and it looks
so much bigger.
The color is a real effect caused by the Earth’s
atmosphere.
The light has to pass through more air near
the horizon…
and air scatters away the blue half of the
spectrum.
The same thing happens with the sun at sunrise
and sunset.
but the hugeness of the Moon is a complete
illusion.
No, for real, it's all in your head.
It’s called the “Moon Illusion” and
it has fascinated humans for a very long time.
To the timeline!
The earliest record we have of the illusion
is from a cuneiform tablet that’s been dated
to the time of King Assur-bani-pal in Ancient
Mesopotamia.
That’s modern-day Iraq, Syria, and Turkey;
but, like, a long time ago!
We also have a record from Ancient China during
the time of Confucius
Back then though, people were convinced it
was a real effect.
They thought the moon must be physically closer
or the optics of the atmosphere must enlarge
the image.
Even Aristotle in Ancient Greece was convinced
it was optical
and we all know how his ideas turned out.
It wasn’t until about 1021 CE that someone
finally questioned it.
Abu Ali al-Ḥasan ibn al-Ḥasan ibn al-Haytham
pioneered the concept of experimentation over
600 years before Galileo making him one of
the first actual scientists.
He suggested optics weren’t quite enough
to explain the moon illusion.
Why can’t it be a real thing?
Because the Moon’s distance from us doesn’t
change very much.
We saw in a previous that the Moon is this
far away from the Earth
and because it’s so far away, any changes
in its distance will go mostly unnoticed.
Yes, the Moon’s orbit is elliptical, but
drawing it like this is misleading.
It looks more like this.
It’s almost circular.
That means, over the course of a month, the
Moon’s distance only changes this much.
That’s not that much.
So anytime the news or your friends are like:
Oh my god! It’s a super moon!
It’s actually not that big of a deal.
There’s nothing super about it!
To make matters worse, the moon looks bigger
on the horizon, where it’s actually farther away
This is the line you look along when the moon
is high in the sky.
But this is the line you look along when the
moon is near the horizon.
That's an entire Earth radius farther!
That alone easily cancels out anything optical
happening in the atmosphere.
So, what’s really going on?
There are actually several different explanations.
Psychologists treat them like they’re competing
explanations,
but, for reasons I’ll make clear later,
I think it’s all of them at the same time.
Let’s do this!
First, my personal favorite: the Ebbinghaus
Illusion.
Your brain actually changes the sizes of things
to add extra contrast.
Take a look at the orange circles in this
picture.
The one surrounded by tiny blue circles looks
bigger,
but, if you remove the blue circles, you can
see they’re the same size.
Even now that you know they’re the same
size, you still see them different.
In fact, if I animate one, you see the orange
circle change size even though it doesn’t
actually change.
The idea is that a similar thing happens to
the Moon when it’s near the horizon.
As the Moon rises, you have a bunch of buildings
and trees to compare it to.
so you’re brain’s all like “Wow, that’s
really big.”
But, then when it gets higher, it’s surrounded
only by the vast emptiness of the night sky,
so it looks smaller.
If you remove everything else from view by,
say, looking through a paper towel roll
or even just looking at everything upside
down
then the Moon illusion is lessened for some
people and eliminated for others.
But, since it’s not eliminated for everyone,
we need more explanation.
The second possible explanation is the Ponzo
Illusion.
This is an example of something we call “size
constancy.”
Basically, our brains know that many things
don’t just randomly change size.
So if we see something like a person get smaller,
our brains just interpret that as though the
person is moving farther away.
The flip-side is that, if something looks
like it’s getting farther away,
but doesn’t change size, then it must be
growing.
So the idea here is, as long as we have the
same kind of receding perspective
with the sky that we do with the ground, it
could happen with the Moon.
When the Moon is near the horizon, it must
be farther away,
but it’s always the same size, so your brain
thinks it’s bigger
and it changes your perception accordingly.
The problem is that very few people think
the horizon Moon looks farther away.
Most people say it looks closer.
Finally, we have the Sky-Dome Model.
Unlike the Ponzo illusion which assumes a
flat sky
the sky-dome model assumes a curved sky above
a flat ground.
It suggests that maybe our brains map all
the really far stuff
like stars and the moon, onto an imaginary
dome above our heads.
The advantage here is that it says we connect
the sky to the ground at the horizon
and, as a result, underestimate the distance
to sky objects.
We saw in the other video that, at best, we
can only see about 3 miles in any direction.
That puts the ground horizon in this picture
about 3 miles away,
so our brains assume the distant clouds in
the sky are also 3 miles away
when those clouds are actually about 10 miles
away.
A huge underestimation.
The thing is though, none of these are dramatic
enough to explain the Moon illusion.
But if we consider all three at the same time,
we might have something.
The Moon illusion is subtle for some and dramatic
for others.
A small fraction of people don’t even see
it.
Maybe that’s because not everyone is affected
the same way by these.
Someone who is greatly affected a lot by all of these,
like, say, my Mom,
is going to just be mind blown by the size
of the Moon every time.
So, how affected are you by the Moon illusion?
Please share in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you want to
keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s ok to
be a little crazy.
In the last video, we learned what was outside
the universe.
Comment response time!
WillCant QuickScope asked what aspects of
the universe were finite.
As I’ve said in the last couple videos,
I would hope all of them, including space.
General opinion among cosmologists though
is that space is infinite,
but all they REALLY know is the entire universe
is at least 20 times bigger than our observable
universe.
Regardless, let’s just say space is infinite.
Time doesn’t appear to be.
There does appear to be a beginning to the
universe.
At least the universe as we know it and time
as we know it.
It began 13.8 billion years ago about 380,000
years before this light was emitted.
Speaking of which, several people asked why
this was oval and not a circle.
It’s a map projection of the distant universe.
The entire inside of the cosmic horizon sphere,
flattened into a plane.
It’s oval for the same reason this map of
the Earth is oval.
Bobby Harper asked what aliens would see if
they lived on the edge of the universe?
No edge!
The universe is either infinite or it curves
back on itself.
Those are your only options.
The universe doesn’t have any edges.
But, if you mean the edge of our observable
universe,
they would just see their own observable universe
around themselves.
Technically, everyone has their own observable
universe around them.
We’re just all a little too close together to notice
a difference.
Tooth and Sticks wonders what the difference
is between “nothing” and “empty space.”
Empty space is just space and time completely
devoid of matter.
Nothingness is a complete lack of even space
or time.
Literally nothing!
Gauge Wiley pointed out that Numberphile did
a video on how far you’d have to travel
to start finding copies of things.
Spoiler Alert: It’s a long way.
Jonathan Spking wants more Camera Shy Clone.
He is adorable, isn’t he?
I’ll see what I can do.
And, for the last order of business,
YouTube is discontinuing normal annotations
on May second this year,
which means we’re stuck with that 20-second
mobile end screen,
so we’re now forced to separate the comment
responses into their own videos.
The last video was a trial run and the response
seemed pretty positive.
This video we’re back to the old end screen
one last time
because I felt like you deserved a little
warning.
Ahhhh!
Change!!!
Look, I don’t like change either, but maybe
I’ll get to respond to more comments?
or at least more detailed responses to the same number of comments.
Anyway, crazies, thanks for watching. See you next time!
What a beautiful Moon tonight.
That’s no moon!
That’s a space station!